trump is telling people he thinks he'll
be reinstated as president on august
business insider story
trump has been telling people things
will tell white house as a sitting
president by august the new york times
reporter maggie
haberman tweeted on tuesday haberman who
broke some of the biggest stories of the
trump administration and has been
covering him
for decades added that trump has been
laser focused on election audits and
states where results he is still trying
to overturn
the anti-democratic conspiracy theory
has been bubbling
up in the french conservative media for
several months it has no bases under the
constitution or any
legitimate legal framework my pelosi or
mike lindell has been
a prominent pro proponent of the theory
the former trump attorney sydney powell
also floated the idea
at a q anon conference which is also
called the
gateway pundit conference over the
weekend
thoughts oh man i got to tell you uh
well
i i hope he's right but on the other
hand man i think they
they stole it fair and square at some
point you just have to you've got to
learn
and uh they they know
what they did they are slow rolling out
their excuses they've now started using
the term fortifying the election they
didn't steal the election they fortified
the election right
and you have that that new york times
i'm sorry it was a
time magazine article that detailed
step by step how they did it and what
they did and when i say they this is not
just the democrats by the way
this is the cheney republicans the bush
faction the neocons
the quote unquote swamp all the war
hawks that wanted us
and and again it tells you everything
you need to know about why biden was
put in power by the powers that be that
after a year and a half of holding the
country political hostage
before they gave a single stimulus check
to any american they gave 250 million
dollars to raytheon and started dropping
bombs on syria
tells you all you need to know about
what washington prioritizes and what
they don't
and trump wasn't giving them their their
blood money trump wasn't
sending people overseas to die and they
didn't like that so they got rid of them
and they did it legally though see they
did steal the election
but they did it legally they did it it
may be corrupt
but it was legally corrupt what they did
in georgia what they did
in in pennsylvania they changed the
election laws
specifically to allow them to cheat if
anything i blame republicans
for not being willing to play in the mud
right if if the democrat dead can vote
why can't the republican dead vote you
have to do what you have to do to win
i'm so sick and tired of republicans
you really believe that's what happened
absolutely if i'm so sick and freaking
tired of republicans wanting to be like
well we did things the right way we were
noble no you lost
at some point if you keep losing you're
not noble you're a sucker
you know what i'm saying like if they
keep changing the rules and you keep
playing by their rules that they don't
even play by
you're not noble you're a sucker well
here's the question are they going to be
able to adapt if that's the different
game plan now that's what we're going to
find out get out
for once we'll see if they're that
visionary you know in a related story to
this one did you hear about nancy pelosi
she says she's going to be the captain
of the laker girls next year
all right that has about as much
relevance yes i am
because it's it's about i was about to
say i had all of you
lost me
i'm mandating this you know you know
here's the thing this is why i
truly believe trump's not running again
because say what you want about him i
don't think he's a complete idiot and
would he want a message like this
out there i mean really this just sounds
so preposterous and so ridiculous
and there's no one with half a brain
cell that actually believes that it's
physically
everything about it is impossible by the
way i'm more interested in the other
trump that's in the news this week
donald trump jr he's hilarious did you
hear he's on cameo now do you know what
he's charging for his videos he's
charging
600 bucks 600 to get a video from uh
donald trump jr he says they need the
money because of all the attacks
from new york absolutely you know from
the attorney general and whatnot so
here's the funniest thing about donald
trump jr's bio
on cameo right for his profile he lists
themselves as a new york times
best-selling author
i mean why would you use the new york
times to
you know to to prop you up when all you
do is rail on them i would i wouldn't i
would take that line out of there but
yeah you know trump just has to isn't
there a rally this week too
i think there's a rally so you know the
crazy big bitcoin is in miami
biggest ever 50 000 are in miami this
week it's a bunch of parties that we're
being invited to i may attend one
i don't know yet i may attend one uh the
only reason i'm saying i may not because
i got you know next week is a pretty
crazy week for us and we're gone but uh
uh yeah we made so look here's here's
what i think about this year okay here's
what i think about this year
so play there's three parties here
number one okay
number one is he's out of his mind
there's no the key word they use which
is their fear
it says it has no it has no basis under
the constitution of
any legitimate legal framework okay so
that's that part
so somebody may say well for decades
they couldn't take the mob
out until somebody came and taught at a
university hey
we wrote this law in here called the
rico law
why don't you guys know so they brought
the attorneys and you know the story
they brought the attorneys in
they trained the attorneys on how to
take the mob down then the attorneys
went out and there was this young
assistant attorney general his name is
mr rudy giuliani we're gonna go after
them
he hires three attorneys to work with
them out of 150 attorneys you have to
choose from the three attorneys he
chooses guess how old these guys are
29 29 30 years old yeah he brings
young bucks who don't have a lot of
experience and they say hey guys they
don't stand on ceremonies
no no they're just like let's just go
figure this thing but they have energy
right and they go
so meaning one end if there's creative
attorneys to be able to figure out
if there's something out there they can
do more power to them second thing
if giuliani is the guy that found the
rico law
and trump hired him and he was charging
around 400 grand a month by the way
when uh giuliani was good
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah year ago so if he
hires them for 400 000
a month 400 000 a month and all they can
get was a landscaping place
that's the point so if that happened and
nothing was able to be figured out
what is that so all these states kemp
georgia all of these things that was
coming back arizona you know hey
they are finding stuff it's just the
democrats have more attorneys they did
things
to the letter of the law after they
changed the law did you hear the one
story came out that one of the
one of the mafia members got three
million dollars and 30 000
uh uh 30 000 what do you call it ballots
to put in oh yeah did you hear about
that story
no here's here's here's what's going on
how about the boxes that were taken away
nobody ever wanted to talk about that
they literally showed the boxes being
taken
off the table put under the table like
it's insanity listen
you know you're talking about a couple
things here we talked about this
yesterday i think it's important for the
audience to be thinking about this so
here's a few things just a hundred years
ago okay just a hundred years ago
gambling was illegal yes just a hundred
years ago gambling was illegal
the first casino legal casino that came
out in new york was what year
1978 the year i was born right
first one in atlantic city right okay in
92 i think it was fox haven
fox whatever it's called kinetic shout
out to uh no fox wants
to shout out to the fox connecticut yeah
that's shout out to
greg dinkins research for us which was
very helpful
next so gambling was illegal the mob was
doing it illegally uh
online sports betting was illegal there
was no bookies
this was five years ago this is five
years but i'm talking about 100 years
ago
50 years ago bookies that were only ran
by the mob and gangsters
you go to uh uh you know loan sharks you
know you were going out there and doing
loan sharking i'll give you a thousand
dollars but you got to give me thirteen
hundred dollars back in a month that's
thirty percent
that's called pay their loans that's
student loans that's student loans
then you have drugs that was being sold
you know illegally
now amazon is supporting marijuana
that bothers me the noise and by the way
do not do do you think in the next
year two years three years amazon's
gonna be selling uh marijuana on their
website
bothers me to know so they just figured
that out the point i'm trying to make to
you is
all of these things were illegal just 50
years ago
now they're multi multi multi-billion
dollar industries that we're talking
about right so so the government and a
lot of these fortune 100 companies took
their ideas from the mob
they're doing it so maybe a lot of these
political parties are sitting there
saying listen man the mob
the people control elections for a long
time hey maybe we ought to go pick up
some of these playbooks and they're
using it and it's working who knows if
it's happening or not
but who's the ring leader on the
republican side to actually organize
this that's the problem so divided look
up if you want to look up something
look up color revolution if you want to
know what happened in america look up
color revolution what
what should scare you about that when
people talk about the quote-unquote deep
state
and you get into the conspiracy theories
it's not a conspiracy
that there are cia operatives and fbi
operatives that are
partisans that have actively tried to
uh uh circumvent our dually elected
process okay they're on record both cia
and fbi and they've done this in other
places when people talk about
they hate us because of our freedoms
people around the world hate us because
no
they hate us because we do like
this to their elections all the time
we interfere in these elections overseas
all the time the way our deep state
interfered in our election this time
we do this across the world but by the
way we got a bunch of activity that took
place and people want us to talk about
the fouchy emails paul
lee brandt gave a hundred dollars so can
we talk about the voucher emails little
rock a hundred dollars i was a russian
linguistic linguist in army during the
80s i was a truck driver during
working through undergrad i have a bs
and an ms an electric computer
engineering i'm now a lawyer and cannot
understand how anyone believes fauci
after the his mask fiasco what do you
think about emails
little rock why don't you text us at
310-340-1132 send us a text at
310-340-1132 and let us know your little
rock and we'll see what we can do here
but
so look here's all i'm saying to you is
if if if the folks on the left or the
right got more creative to win
salute if they broke the law score
they've got to be held accountable but
if they figured it i figured out a way
to get away with it
you were creative what what what did our
president say our sitting president the
the most popular president of all time
by the way got more votes than both
donald trump
and barack obama can't put a full sent
coaching sentence together
greatest campaigners of all time
greatest campaign
he he spoke at least once a month on the
campaign trail guy was tireless
got a top-notch son man hunter oh
again again but there's there's no
corruption in the in our fbi at all
none uh all right yeah what did he say
though patrick and this and this should
scare them because
if they're trying to go with that last
line that you said is there that's their
line of defense that's the mainstream
there's no constitutional
what did what did joe biden say didn't
joe biden i don't forget what the exact
quote was it was something like there's
nothing in the constitution
that's that that that's forever
everything in congress oh
when he was talking about stacking the
court everything in the constitution is
available to change with my leg hair and
popeye's was bad dude yeah this is
reaching out on the inside of my leg
they used to braid my hair
well i have hope and optimism i think
there's enough people
that might be okay you know good people
i don't think you can keep this secret
if
if laws were broken i don't think so i
think eventually over time
eventually yes but what's eventually uh
years unfortunately give me a time
two to three years i mean i disagree no
there's too many people involved i don't
think it ever does i i
one of the most funny i think it's 30
years see that's why i believe we went
to the next generation
it's a legacy for sure i think it's 30
years you're going to the movies you're
sitting there saying no freaking way
kids are like that would never happen
we're like we lived through this
but it's a movie 30 years from now kind
of like argo explaining what happened in
here
yeah but it's the most sorry the most
the most
just because it goes on this the most
formative book i've ever read in my life
the book that i read that most formed my
my world view is the gulag archipelago
all right by alexander soshnichkin
right and his one of his biggest lines
if you don't have you ever read the
gulag archipelago
he wrote this while he was in the gulag
he was a political dissident in congress
pull up this book so people can't see
what anything is talking about he had to
hide it he wrote this over the course of
10 years while he was a political
prisoner
he had to write it and then he published
it it was illegal
it was punishable by 10 years hard labor
in russia if you were caught reading
this book when it came out in 1978
and it describes all of the horrors
of far leftist communist tyrannical
governments and and how it represses
freedom
and one of the lines in the very
beginning of the book is
we know they are lying they know that we
know
they are lying we know that they know
that we know they are lying
and yet still they continue the lie and
that is the power
say that one more time that one more
time
we know they're lying okay this is
alexander stolzness yep
we know they're lying they know that we
know
that they're lying we know that they
that we know they are lying and yet
still they continue to lie
powerful that is the power principle
powerful
that's the gall of the powerful they'll
do whatever it they did whatever it
takes to get power
now they have to do whatever it takes to
keep it
there you go so in reality i think what
we're all saying is nothing's going to
change this election
unless we change it no but with the next
three years you think anything's going
to change well 50 50
senate and yeah this midterm is going to
be a bloodbath
how about you this midterm it has to be
it has to be a ground war
yeah but what do you think it's going to
flip do you think the house is going to
fly i think in order to make the house
flip
you have to match what they're doing you
have to take their place you got to
start now because the elections next
year
it needed it needed to start it didn't
start two years ago when their action
front how much is trump needed for that
how much does trump need to see i go
back and forth that's a great question i
go back and forth
because he riles up his side but he also
activates the other side
and that's something where like desantis
i think activates
his side without activating the other
side
i it's a really really interesting thing
this could win i do i
i especially think a a coalition of
desantis and a tulsi
or a desantis on a mansion and it it it
won't happen
for for donation reasons but i tell you
a coalition
party like that a coalition where the
santa claus sanctions
oh my god don't forget tulsi comes over
look what tulsi did to kamala
twice already she would she would have
to debate kamala again
if she was the vp here's the problem
with trump um he could
empower a big flip in the house if he
could
he can't think small that's his problem
so if you were equated to an actor all
he can think about is being in a
blockbuster movie and winning an academy
award he's not going to go off broadway
he doesn't give a damn about that same
thing in baseball he wants to play in
the world series
doesn't care about the minor leagues he
could get a groundswell of support to
help flip the house
and be and be a real force that way but
all he can think about and all he can
talk about
is they're going to reinstate me in
august he's only thinking about the
biggest prize
when they actually could use the power
that he has on the ground level
he's also to your point at 60 minutes
he's going to talk
59 minutes of that is going to be
powerful his base is going to be happy
he's going to say one thing in 60
minutes
that's going to be a sound bite that
again is then used and played
to activate the other side it's going to
it's going to be manipulated he can't
help himself but being edgy and
and he he wants that sound bite he wants
to dominate the news cycle he thinks
in in terms of media and again what
what's sun tzu what does sun soon say
right never never stop your enemy when
he's defeating himself
like that's what he does all the time
the best thing the republicans have done
in the last two years is shut up
and let people hear what democrats are
actually saying right let them hear what
you're actually saying like whoa
what's this green new deal hold on if i
give you all my money you're gonna
change the weather
like wait you know what trump has to
worry because you talk about playing
dirty that district attorney in new york
will do whatever she possibly can to
take him down absolutely and i think
that's his biggest battle right now he's
got some
some serious issues on the legal front
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you